5 56 into monday morning a nightmare on
nellis is driving somebody crazy viewer
crystal
writes about the pedestrian crosswalk at
nellis and
cedar that's between bonanza and stuart
she says
the crosswalk is not marked well and
folks ignore the fact that you're there
she says they need to put flashing
lights and mark the crosswalk have been
almost hit several times by speeding
drivers
and she points out it is a clearly
marked school zone well crystal i don't
know if there are any plans to address
that crosswalk itself but i want to make
sure you know
the nevada department of transportation
just started a nearly 26 million dollar
project to repave
10 miles of nellis from tropicana on the
south all the way up to craig road on
the north
it's happening in three phases phase one
started last month from prop up to
sahara
phase two from sahara to owens that's
gonna start in april of next year
i don't know that they're gonna be
putting a flashing light in at nellis
and cedar
but you'd have to figure that the
crosswalk is gonna be restriped as part
of the repaving
i'll send your note over to the ndot
folks and see what they say a reminder
that there will be two new crosswalks
put in
ellis is part of the project there's one
at newton that's between harmon and
trump the other one is just north of
cheyenne
crystal thanks for writing in buckle up
drive carefully please put down that
phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com